hello everyone and welcome to another
incredible game also from the final
round of the European Championship where
we catch a glimpse of the of the legend
himself of the immortal uh evanchook and
here in this game he shows just why he
was feared by pretty much every player
in the world when he was in his Peak but
even nowadays he can just uh you know uh
come through any position and find the
uh the the correct reply uh so let's see
what this is all about he's facing a
strong azerbaijani Grandmaster Muhammad
muradli uh so let's see what happened
here we have D4 Knight to F6 uh C for E6
we have Knight to F3 and pawn to D5 so
this is the Queen's Gambit Decline and
yeah I forgot to mention before we check
out the game uh today Chad gpt4 was
released and I was uh trying it out uh
trying you know checking out what it can
do and I asked I I actually asked taji
petite to annotate this game as if it
were a 19th century nobleman and the
this is the introduction for the game
that it gave me gather round esteemed
ladies and gentlemen as we Regale you
with the tale of the noble chess context
that betwixt the esteemed sir evanchook
and the formidable Lord muradli their
width and strategy shall be unraveled in
a most delightful manner befitting the
eloquence of the 19th century nobility
uh it goes on but uh you know it's true
you can truly do Marvels with it you
know if I had something like this when I
was doing The morphe Saga you know who
who knows how how it might have turned
out but okay getting back to this game
and I might even throw in some morphe
games in there just to see what it comes
up with so if it's going to be fun I'm
going to share it so D5 with Knight to
C3 Bishop to E7 uh and now Bishop to F4
we have castles and now Queen to C2 here
the standard is E3 Queen to C2 is fairly
rare but we're gonna transpose into the
unknown lines of theories so the
captures captures with E3 fonta C6 and
Bishop D3 putting pressure on that H7
Pawn so you have to be careful Rook gate
we have castles and now Knight to f8 we
have H3 Knight to G6 Bishop to H2 as the
bishop and F4 was attacked Bishop to D6
in here vassal trades with characters
captures and The Rook 8 and B1 now uh we
have Pawn to A5 as vassal announced by
playing Rook a to B1 he wants to play B4
so of course uh Muhammad uh stops IT
Rook F to C1 and now comes Queen to E7
and uh there are some games were
worshiped the E6 was played but here we
have Queen to E7 and it is now as of
move 15 that we have a completely new
game
uh so Knights the D2 uh control uh
fighting for that E4 square but now
Knight the H4 with G3 attacking the
Knight and queen to D7 going after the
H3 pawn and uh capturing the Knight is
possible but it yields only a draw uh I
will just show it because it is uh
supposedly the strongest move
recommended by the engine now you have
to play Bishop F1 attack the queen and
after this bishop to G2 so you don't
have to worry about something like
Knight G4 Queen H2 check Queen F2
Checkmate the bishop stops that but
still Bishop H3 is a very very
unpleasant let's say Knight to F3 uh
Queen to G4 threatens Checkmate now
Knights the E1 defense and okay now
there's really nothing better than to
capture Queen H3 now like the G4 is
coming you're gonna play Knight to F4
attack the black queen if Queen G4 check
you're gonna go back and probably would
see something like a repetition here so
instead after this queen 37 move uh
Queen to D1 Russell does not touch the
Knight on H4 and okay you don't want to
overstay your welcome Knight to F5 with
Knight the E2 and now Knight the D6 now
the E4 square is looking uh excellent so
Knight to F4 and now we have Knight F
the E4 a beautifully placed Knight there
we have H4 and now Pawn to F6 we have
Knight captures and E4 Knight captures
on e4 and now Rook the C2 font G5 uh uh
Murado is really going for that King
side attack he wants the uh he wants to
break through on the king side uh Knight
the H5 now you have to be careful uh
here vasel is threatening to eliminate
the defender of the F6 pawn and then
Knight captures on F6 will land with a
monster Fork so Queen to F7 defending
the pawn and now H Capers and G5 F
captures and pawn G4 just defending the
Knight on H5 Rook the f8 now putting uh
a fair amount of pressure on that F2
pawn and pawn to F4 and this is a
wonderful movie if it works you know
that you're gonna have a good game
because if it doesn't you just fall
apart the problem is here after captors
you're going to play Bishop captures on
e4 and after oh you don't really
gain anything by recapturing just Knight
captures and then the Knight controls
the queen and the rook and if you try
something sneaky like Pawn to F3 uh and
for let's say white tries to save the
bishop okay then maybe you can have a
nice attack but white will just give
back the material right away and then
we're just gonna see a trade captures
captures captures and captures and
probably sound like Rook F2 Rook
captures here uh you're gonna double up
on the f file and uh not just Bishop to
E6 Bishop captures and G4 is impossible
uh because you just go Knight F6 check
and pick up the bishop or Rook G2 check
and then you pick up the Rook G2 uh you
you don't allow the bishop to move and
then you capture it so uh without this
capture it's still fine for for both
sides but instead of G captures and F4
we have Knight back to F6 uh and now
Knight captures on F6 with check Queen
captures and now Pawn to F5 now visel
can be very happy as he prevented the
attack from happening uh but not quite
yet H5 now threatens the weaken the base
of the pawn chain Rook the F2 and now
Bishop to D7 and here we have G captures
on H5 this is the uh first move
recommended by the engine because the
engine pretty much always grabs upon and
the vassal plays it showing that uh he
he uh knows how to play chess uh Rook 8
to E8 with Queen to F3 and now King to
H7 preparing to block the pawn with King
to H6 and you will be very very safe
there Queen to G3 now the queen has
access to this diagonal which could be
very important King the H6 and now A3
trying to get that pawn to B4 in but
um
Muhammad uh prevents it again with a
pawn to A4 with Bishop to C2 by Russell
going after the A4 pawn and now comes
Rook the E7 and this is truly a
spectacular moment in the game uh where
uh okay you don't really want to go
after the A4 Pawn uh because the bishop
is also needed to defend the F5 Pawn
it's being attacked by the bishop by the
queen and by The Rook but again it is
the top move recommended by the engine
and uh even Chuck plays it he plays
Bishop captures on A4 and it looks like
a move a Potter would play but it's a
very as always ingests it's a very thin
line between a Potter and the genius and
uh you know uh you have to be careful
when playing such moves but vassal
calculates correct correctly and now uh
Bishop captures an F5 is impossible but
you have to calculate very deeply uh to
understand why his opponent missed it he
played Bishop captures on F5 and now
look at this Rook beat the F1 uh of
course now the the bishop cannot move
but just Queen to E6 and pinning and now
what's the move that vassal saw when he
played Bishop captures on A4 uh that is
possible in this position now feel free
to pause the video and to win the game
for Russell uh while I give you a couple
of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on spotting this
uh instant resigns move for black and
for those of you who just want to enjoy
the show it is Pawn to E4 so
congratulations to everyone who found it
it's a very very forcing idea and it
doesn't leave
um any options uh for black uh obviously
you can't capture with the bishop
because the Rook captures an f8 and also
yeah congratulations to everyone who
found this uh you you are a true master
of finding a correct a correct path in
complicated positions uh but it still
seems a very unlikely Queen captures
d-capters this is all possible how is
this uh so crushing for white the
problem is if Queen captures you have
Bishop to C2 the root guards the bishop
and now are you just a blunder a piece
but even this look at this queen
captures on D4 now pins The Rook so you
don't have to worry about the bishop on
F5 but now comes the bishop captures on
F5 and now you realize it was never the
bishop you had to worry about it was the
rook and on E7 and now out Rook chapters
and F5 Queen to D6 with check and that
just loses a black too much material
King captures Queen captures on E7 and
you are now down a full Rook so
absolutely incredible so that's why
after Pawn to E4 the captures on e4 was
played but now again you have Bishop to
B3 again the queen defends the bishop
you have to move from this diagonal
Queen to D7 and now Rook captures an F5
The Rook on E7 is the real Target of the
line and that's what uh even chook saw
when he played Bishop captures on A4 and
if you also saw that then okay uh you
you are truly a spectacular chess player
so Rook captures on F5 was played Rook
captures on F5 and now okay if you
capture them Queen to D6 check picks up
the Rook here King captures Queen but
now not Queen captures on E7 that's the
the the interesting part because then
Queen to G4 check and black will get a
Perpetual first to play Bishop D1 check
and then uh well there's really not much
you can here if you go King stage four
you just get checkmated and it's quite
the Checkmate Queen page to Checkmate as
Bishop covers the light squares you
would have to play something after
Bishop to D1 check like G4 but it's not
much better Queen captures now you don't
have to worry about Queen to G4 check
and it's just a upper Bishop uh so
afterward captures on F5 Queen captures
and D4 check was played this is um uh
Muhammad's last attempt and now King to
H1 with Queen to D2 and now Rook to F6
with check uh we have King to H7 and now
Rook to F2 and he was in this position
animal 44 that Mohammed muradli resigned
the game as there is nothing more to be
done here uh here the problem is okay
you could throw in some checklist the
queen T1 check uh King to G2 and now
even E3 looks uh looks scary but uh look
at this bishop to C2 check King has to
move King to G8 and now Queen to B8 with
check with King to G7 and now Queen to
f8 to check is only one of the lines
that ends in Checkmate there are many uh
and all of them end in Checkmate so
after Rook F2 they are morally resigned
and what a brilliant victory for at the
legend vastly even chook but yeah he had
to see it after Rook D7 he had the zero
capture the bishop capture 784 and this
is always important uh even in your own
games even though the action is on the
king side you know this is a very
important Pawn but this Pawn is hanging
so you know try to waste a a few minutes
if you have them uh calculating the
exact idea because here uh it's
definitely the strongest move and it
allowed for This brilliant seat to
happen uh so yeah that's the game hope
you guys enjoyed it very nicely done by
by the legend himself I would like to
thank an anonymous person happy 33 lost
one Dennis chardonnell and Felix daffo
for a contribution to my channel thank
you a lot I really appreciate it as
usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching and I
will see you soon continuing to check up
on you wonderful suggestions and
whatever else happens in the Chess World
so thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day